Hey,
wisecrack disembodied jared again here
to continue our epic philosophy of
Christopher Nolan trilogy.
In our first installment,
Nolan begins.
We covered his interpretations of the
self in his early films plus inception.
What does it mean to be a self?
How can we trust ourselves and our own
thoughts?
Today we're asking if there's so much
conflict already present in the self.
What are the implications for a
community full of cells if we can't even
handle our own issues?
Is it possible to avoid conflict with
other people or is violence inevitable?
This is the foundational questions
surrounding Gotham City in the dark
knight trilogy,
so suit up for some time with the Batman
and were not wearing hockey pads.
Welcomeness wisecrack addition on the
philosophy of Christopher Nolan Park
too,
and Yup,
there's spoilers ahead behind the face.
Paint and pointy eared masks.
Gotham is experiencing crisis after
crisis that affect the functioning of
its social body.
The mob is pumping and drugs.
The cops are helping the mob.
The mob is hiring.
Clowns and bomb seem to be getting
trendier by the minute.
Batman may be the focus,
but his focus is on the city he loves.
In the process of saving Gotham,
the film's raised questions about the
nature of community.
How does a society deal with fear and
threats?
How does the presence of a hero like
Batman creates or threatened stability?
Can Society wide conflict ever be
resolved or is it inherently a cyclical
process?
What about escalation escalation where
you start tearing semiautomatics day bio
waste,
dod wearing Kevlar body armor piercing
rounds,
and you're wearing a mask?
Jumping off rooftops,
help us understand Nolan's social
philosophy.
We're turning to perpetually stoned
looking anthropologists.
Rene's Gerard Gerard claims that the
concept of [inaudible] is both the
foundation of all societies and the
foundation of conflict in those
societies.
Gerard's theory claims that one of the
most basic aspects of our relationships
with other people is imitation.
Imitation can be as simple as copying
someone else's behavior.
I see you buying someone a bad ass
necklace and I think,
wow,
great idea,
and I decided to go buy a necklace to
everyone's happy,
right?
But this can become a problem.
Gerard says that imitation of someone
else's behaviors can and often does lead
to replicating their desires.
That's where I don't just want a
necklace.
I want that necklace to one you happen
to be wearing.
This is mimetic desire and it can pretty
quickly lead to rivalry where multiple
people share the same desire and so
compete over finite resources.
Gerard claims that are human impulse
toward imitation means that eventually
more and more people will want that
necklace and rivalries will grow and
multiply until they're also profoundly
impactful on the community itself.
When one succeeds in winning the prize,
the other people or their tribes or
their surviving family members seek
retaliation against the winter.
This vengeance is also a form of
imitation and it basically ensures that
rivalries and violence will continue to
grow.
According to Gerard.
This is the fundamental reason why there
is crime,
violence,
and war in the world.
As Batman begins begins.
This turmoil is already established,
obviously because according to Gerard,
this cycle goes all the way back to
cavemen,
but what's important to note here is
that we see individual examples of
mummies occurring and motivating
characters and most importantly it later
on we see Nolan used mimetic theory to
propose a possible solution to society
wide violence.
So let's get started.
Let me.
This is most relevant in Batman begins
as it relates to the individual,
especially in the creation of the Batman
identity.
The original instance of this,
this is one man's desire for the Wayne's
wealth,
which leads to violence throughout the
film,
Nolan for grounds,
fear and vengeance as powerful
motivators,
especially in a city as broken as
Gotham.
We see this again in Bruce's imitation
of his parents.
Killer Joe,
chill in his effort to exact vengeance
versus time away from Gotham inspires
him to move away from the cycle of
vengeance that motivated him to avenge
his parents.
Instead,
he uses invitation as a means of
stopping violence.
His fear of bats leads him to adopt the
identity of a bat,
but he uses this invitation as a means
to spread the fear to criminals who now
fear a different kind of back him
watching your seeking justice.
The League of shadows wants to press the
reset button on conflict by destroying a
society altogether,
but that's not really how it works.
The problem with their method is that
watching people destroy each other
doesn't actually do anything to decrease
violence.
It inflates it.
There's nothing for people to unite
around,
so whatever survivors are left after the
fire of London or the black plague or
the microwaving of Gotham art still
going to be really pissed off.
So if the League of shadows gets it
wrong,
what does Batman get right?
Even while Nolan presents us with the
idea that it is difficult,
if not impossible to break away from
violence.
Roost spends.
The majority of Batman begins struggling
to overcome both his fears and his
impulse for vengeance.
It can't be personal where you're just
vigilante.
In order to do that,
that man has to transcend the identity
of Bruce Wayne and become something
else.
And image in the collective
consciousness that represents justice
without personal motivation,
he has to become a symbol to be imitated
and it's this idea of symbols Gerard
proposes that can break society out of
violence.
Unlike the more individually focused
themes of Batman begins.
The dark knight transitions to these
social consequences of the rapid spread
of rivalries and fear.
After the mobs ass whooping,
the city begins to push back against
organized crime and the faces of this
effort,
our Rv Dent new district attorney and
got them White Knight and Batman.
The wait for it dark night while the bat
fights with battery and Harvard
Lamborghinis Dent Fights,
crime using the law as his weapon.
The White Knight and the Dark Knight are
symbiotic ideas.
They both inspire imitation.
While dent inspires the rest of the city
government to aim for a safer Gotham,
Batman Inspires copycats in poorly
conceived Halloween costumes.
Still those copycats are assigned and
that the idea of Batman inspires hope
among the citizens of Gotham.
It's also a sign that those citizens are
copying his tactic of replicating fear
or at least trying to,
but the mob pushes back as mobs tend to
do,
and the increasing escalation of
conflict between the Knights and the
criminals leads to Moroni.
Hiring the joker to kill Batman.
Part of the danger of the joker is that
he only has power because of how afraid
the mob is.
Listen,
I know why you choose to have these
little group therapy sessions in broad
daylight.
I know why you're afraid to go out at
night.
Batman Strategy for fighting crime has
created a monster one that feeds on the
mimetic reproduction of fear that that
man relies on.
So how can you break a cycle that has
adapted to your methods of opposing?
Gerard tells us that when violence and
vengeance become so great that they
threatened the existence of the society,
the majority of people will quickly set
aside their differences in order to
sacrifice an individual the scapegoat
whose death can restore temporary peace
to the community.
Everyone agrees that the whole thing was
the scapegoats fault and Bam,
boom,
burned at the metaphorical steak.
And everyone chills out,
but since it's literally impossible for
an immense social conflict to be
entirely one person's fault,
the scapegoat is a lie and a pretty
violent one at that.
So peace doesn't last long and
eventually someone cupboards by
neighbors necklace all over again.
Gerard says that since humans have an
innate impulse toward violence and
rivalry actually stopping those cycles
of vengeance is basically impossible.
With one exception,
we can replace the scapegoat goat with a
Christ like figure who rejects violence
and turn the other cheek,
and this could set a new imitative trend
of people desiring nonviolence,
Harvey Dent and his campaign for peace
in Gotham appear to fill that role,
providing a Christ figure for the
community to emulate.
I believe in Harvey,
even Batman who can only fight violence
with violence supports a world where
dent replaces him taking up the mantle
of crime,
fighting without the need for grappling
hooks them off.
I could never be your stance against
organized crime.
It's the first legitimate ray of light
and cousin in decades,
but the joker,
a representation of the true violence of
mankind shifts the course of the mimetic
rivalry.
And corrupts our Christ figure with a
few oil drums and some sweet talk.
Once Harvey to face begins to imitate
the joker,
embracing chaos and going after Gordon
and the corrupt cops,
he becomes subject to the cycles of
violence that the white knight was
supposed to destroy.
So in order to restore peace to Gotham,
we turned to the time honored tradition
of the scapegoat.
Gotham picks an individual.
You're not blames him for the current
social ills in this case,
the crimes committed by two face and the
joker's presence and punishes him in
order to end the intense rivalries that
threatened the existence of the
community.
They don't kill Bruce Wayne,
but they effectively killed the symbol
of the bat and at least for a while and
during the period where Batman is gone,
there is a time of relative peace and
prosperity in the city,
but the scapegoat is always based on a
lie.
The truth of the situation has to be
unconsciously suppressed in order to
achieve the desired effect for
containing the violent impulses of
humanity.
However,
this lie is unsustainable and this
problem is the starting point of the
dark knight rises.
Third film begins at a time of relative
tranquility,
brought on and sustained by the lie of
Harvey Dent's martyrdom and the
scapegoating of Batman.
This is acknowledged by court,
wasn't needed anymore.
We want who just by recognizing the
nature of the lie threatens the
stability that depends on the mayor is
going to dump him in the spring,
really,
but he's a hero,
a war hero.
This is peace time,
but while the dent act made possible by
the demonization of that man has
effectively ended organized crime,
there are other kinds of violence still
at work in the city.
The social and economic inequalities
which defined the third film as one form
of violence ends.
Another begins,
although it's hardly fair to say that
social inequality is a new phenomenon in
Gotham.
[inaudible] were killed because of their
wealth,
but the disillusion of the mob means
that the divides between the legitimate
rich and the poor are once again in the
spotlight and violent rivalry is
inevitable.
I kind of wonder how you ever leave,
so for the rest like
the joker,
Bain is focused on revealing the
violence that already exists in ordinary
people,
but while the joker explores the idea of
chaos,
Bain is interested in the concept of the
law.
There were big supplier with a false to
stop tearing down this corrupt which
undoes the piece that on that lie,
the disruption of the myth of the scape
goat means that the sacrifice of Batman
no longer serves its purpose and its
disappearance no longer helps the city
because Batman's sacrificed himself in
order to save the city from itself.
His return isn't as simple as hopping
into a flying car and catching the bad
guy to inspire the city.
He has to metaphorically come back from
the dead,
which is shown in his ascent out of the
pit.
There's probably a lot of birth
symbolism happening as he climbs out of
a hole into the sunlight.
But what's way more interesting is this
explicit connection to rising from the
dead and the comics.
The underground cave has another name,
the Lazarus pit.
If you're not up to date with your new
testament stories,
Lazarus is a dude who died and Jesus
brought him back to life.
Yes,
pretty much.
That simple,
he rose from the dead.
Coincidence,
probably not,
especially since later on,
Gordon reads a eulogy from a tale of two
cities which describes,
you guessed it,
be Christ like sacrifice of one of the
main characters,
Nolan man,
you're killing it with these lit
references,
and this leads us back to Gerard's
Christ figure.
He claims that in order to have real
lasting peace to remove our society and
ourselves from the cycle of violence,
we need to set aside the myth of the
scapegoat and embrace a figure who sets
an example of selflessness that forms a
new mimetic desire to be copied by the
masses,
but even Gerard isn't sure that this is
feasible if humans are driven by an
innate desire for violence,
isn't realistic to hope for something
different.
Gerard says that even in today's
Christian communities,
people don't really follow Christ's
example.
No one asks this question throughout the
trilogy is peace actually possible.
People battle their inner monsters and
at the same time they're battling the
monsters of Gotham,
but can either of these ever find true
resolution?
It may appear that dent was a fake
Christ figure.
At the end of the dark night,
while Batman becomes a legitimate Christ
figure at the end of the dark,
knight rises,
but is this really the case?
When Batman takes the bomb out over the
ocean,
he saves the city from a very visible
kind of violence,
the radioactive kind,
but the piece that follows is also based
in part on the lie that Batman
sacrificed his life to save the city.
He gets a statue and the city gets a new
martyr,
but maybe the lie of Batman's death is
outweighed by another trip that unliked
end.
He really did fight violence with self
sacrifice,
creating the potential for a new kind of
mimetic desire.
Anyone can copy his motivations even if
atomic bombs are in short supply.
That was the point
and we see [inaudible] come full circle
in Joseph Gordon Levitt character who is
revealed at the end of the film to be
none other than Robin.
The fact that Robin is introduced and
that Batman left him,
all of his crime fighting tools
suggests,
but doesn't prove that piece may not
last in Gotham,
so how do we maintain stability in our
communities?
The openness of the ending person,
Italy,
robin in the bat cave and Batman all
statute up lead us in a number of
directions which is exactly Nolan's
point is a scape goat myth or a lie
necessary to maintain stability.
Can a Christ figure really inspire
people to abandon their violent urges or
Ken Society never exist without
conflict,
no matter what we do.
Is there always a future crisis on the
horizon ultimately to the limits of
human nature?
Prevent us from achieving lasting peace
or does the human spirit's allow us to
overcome whatever obstacles may arise?
No one's later films like interstellar
and Dunkirk.
Give us a peek into the possibility of
how and why we might transcend those
limits like constructing new worlds.
Tune in next time and thanks for
watching.
Thanks for watching.
Wisecrack.
We just want to take a second to thank
you for all the support.
We love making videos for you guys,
but we really couldn't do it without
you,
so another way you can support us is by
becoming a patron.
You'll get immediate access to exclusive
patron only releases,
including podcast.
A new video on the movie is,
and more than a week before it hits the
channel in October.
Early access to our upcoming video on
Mr.
Robot,
and we're working on more patron
exclusives each month,
including behind the scenes experiments
with new formats like movie reviews,
quick takes and more.
So be sure to check out our patrion page
here or at the Lincoln that description,
and if you liked this video and are
looking for more Nolan checkout our
wisecrack condition on the philosophy of
Christopher Nolan Park one by clicking
here.
Thanks a lot.
You guys.